el primer ataque aéreo sobre territorios
palestinos en casi 20 años cerca de
llenín tres personas murieron a raíz de
un ataque con drones por parte del
ejército israelí mismo que Argumenta
haber identificado una célula terrorista
por lo que uno de sus drones empezó a
disparar la violencia escaloensis
Jordania el miércoles en el pueblo de
turbus allá bomberos palestinos apagaron
un incendios atribuidos a colonos judíos
había unos 200 o 250 colonos e
intentaron entrar en el patio prendieron
fuego a los coches y empezaron a
disparar contra la casa utilizando
munición real y piedras e intentaron
destrozar Los Balcones
varias acciones similares se llevaron a
cabo desde la noche del martes en
represalia por el tiroteo en una
gasolinera cerca al asentamiento judío
de élite un ataque que se cobró la vida
de cuatro israelíes y los dos asal
palestinos a los pocos minutos del
ataque jamás Indicó que el tiroteo fue
en respuesta a la mortal incursión
militar israelí en el campo de yening en
ambos campamentos el miércoles se lloró
a los muertos como aquí en chilo un
asentamiento judío en el norte de
cisjordania donde alrededor de un
centenar de personas asistieron al
funeral de la adolescente que murió en
el tiroteo junto con otros tres
israelíes el miércoles el Primer
Ministro israelí benjaminé tanyahu
anunció su intención de construir mil
nuevas viviendas en el asentamiento de
Eli